[Music]
happy birthday John hello John happy
birthday I'm a Buddhist on the books
back John sad Pig and I want to wish you
a happy birthday
hi John happy birthday applicant Rick
won't John have a tubby jokes made of
awesome birthday John has come to my
attention that you're turning 30
haha your old good girl
happy birthday John happy birthday John
Oh John greedy at 30 it kind of sucks
for you you're getting older by the
minute and you'll start to feel it soon
you'll start getting shorter your joints
will sets you aim and since we have so
much applause well hey I'm gonna show
you how to eat a blender eyes happy meal
so I'm gonna blenderize your cake this
curtly says John and nerds are here this
is how dedicated I am to Brotherhood 2.0
and the nerdfighters we're going to
blend birthday cake so here we have our
special birthday cupcake mmm if you have
to get mutilated
blender tool cake a little bit of cake
chocolate raisin otter pops orange piece
your absolute favorite we killed the
blender stupid to you John three two one
taste great you should try something
really that's actually really good
really good actually really good it
doesn't look good it looks good the
flesh became in shape
it's delicious blend rised is not like
the weirdest chocolate I've ever had I
pity your happy meal
congratulations on living and being a
nerdfighter for 30 years so both the
giver Chauhan
Oh
you